des voitures à perte de vue quittant
marioupol ville assiégée depuis trois
semaines bombardés nuitées jour sur les
pare-brise un sauf-conduit des pancartes
avec le mot enfant en alphabet
cyrillique
partir lorsque c'est encore possible
pour ne pas périr sous les bombes sur
une image l'union le seul mot pour
décrire ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui
et insultes et génocide génocide de
notre nation de notre peuple ukrainien
dit le maire de la ville
lueur d'espoir au lendemain du
bombardement du théâtre de mario paul
des survivants ont été dégagés des
décombres
et les ukrainiens continuent de résister
dans ces images de la garde nationale
d'ukraine se blinder russe marqué d'un z
a été touché un homme en sort et prend
la fuite les frapru sont aussi touchés
une piscine municipale de la ville des
civils des femmes et des enfants s'y
étaient réfugiés les nouvelles
aujourd'hui sont surtout
particulièrement préoccupante pour des
civils qui sont dans la ville de
marioupol aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas
accès à la ville de paris où paul nous
ne pouvons pas y aller nous ne pouvons
pas envoyer matériel médical et
chirurgical
pompe à évacuer les blessés
les besoins marioupol et ailleurs dans
le pays son client s'était personnes qui
sont dans des abris des personnes qui
n'ont quasiment plus tôt ou nourriture
personnes qui cherchent à obtenir de la
nourriture de l'eau par n'importe quelle
source ce soit des radiateurs que ce
soit à l'extérieur qu'ils soient en
collectant les autres puis si jamais il
pleut
dans ce hangar de la croix rouge
internationale
on décharge les humanitaires des kits de
chirurgie de guerre ou de première
nécessité
une aide bienvenue mais de l'aveu même
du porte parole de la croix rouge il est
de plus en plus difficile de l'acheminer
vers les villes assiégées les parties au
conflit non n'ont pas trouvé d'accord
concret pour faciliter une sortie
massive de la population de la ville
donc quand on parlait encore concret on
parle de choses de manière très
pragmatique d'horaires de route de du
temps qui va être offert aux personnes
pour quitter la ville est l'endroit
vraiment un sujet aujourd'hui
qu'on peut faire c'est être prêt si la
situation évolue et qu'on pouvait avoir
accès même que les gens pour les sortir
partout dans le pays le ciel est sombre
les villes se réveille sur des colonnes
de fumée et se couche sur des incendies
causés par les bombardements
comme tendent ukrainien sept personnes
pleurent un être cher
ici s1000 khayat radio canada montréal